[Musique]
les shadoks continue a raté le plus
possible décès et plusieurs fois par
jour en automne le compte à rebours au
son de l'accordéon
m
on sait
rires
tout cela évidemment faisait pas mal de
bruit et les shadoks tomba qui comme
vous le savez soutenait la planète s'en
plaignent qu'ils disaient que sa maison
peut se réfléchir que j'en avais assez
et que c'est tout ça ne s'est pas j'irai
tout se couche et qu'ils ne
soutiendraient plus rien du tout et que
la planète est bref c'était de
l'intimidation pur et simple car il
savait très bien que si la planète
drogba je serais tombé avec et ça ne les
intéressait pas tellement elle
protestait qu'on aime pour les apaiser
les shadoks d'en haut et est obligé de
le renvoyer d'énormes quantités de
nourriture par des petits conduit
spéciaux creusé à cet effet mais plus on
leur en donne l'air plus ils ont
redemandé
[Musique]
et quand il n'y aurait plus rien à
manger
[Musique]